[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es diese
wunderschöne zweistöckige hochzeitstorte
ich hab gedacht auf meinem kanal gibt es
eigentlich es gibt nur verlobungs torte
glaube ich es gibt ein baby shower torte
also schon so viele torten aber so
speziell nach selbst dort habe ich euch
noch gar nicht gezeigt und das habe ich
mir zum anlass genommen heute euch
schritt für schritt mit zu nehmen es
wird eine sehr fruchtige und leckere
torte zweistöckig wie gesagt und das
ganze mit diesem wunderschönen blumen
drapiert wenn ihr anfänger seid dann
könnt ihr das auf jeden fall nach meiner
anleitung nachmachen da brauchte ich gar
keine sorgen zu machen und ja ich würde
sagen gelingt direkt los bei einer
verlobung oder hochzeitstorte könnt ihr
zum beispiel die böden auf jeden fall am
vortag vorbereiten das rate ich euch
auch dann habt ihr nämlich am tag der
zusammenstellung erstens kein stress und
zweitens ist es super wenn die bürger
einfach noch mal ein tag ruhen können
ziehen können dann kommen sie auch nicht
so doll und die sind einfach viel
einfacher zu verarbeiten und ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal meine böden einmal
für das obere stockwerk hier habe ich
einen durchmesser von 18 cm genommen und
einen durchmesser von 24 cm fürs untere
stockwerk bei den 18 cm böden habe ich
einfach die den teig quasi aufgeteilt
und in zwei typen ringe gegeben ich
schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben und in die info
box fürs gesamte für die gesamte torte
und auch die backzeit also alles was wir
wissen es steht hier unten in der
infobox und ich habe gerade für meine
standard bis gebäuden zum basic rezept
aus wiesbachschule dass ich da immer
darauf verweisen kann ich mich ja auch
nicht dass das video endlos lang geht es
soll einfach praktisch sein sollte gut
nachmachen können und daher habe ich
euch das video einfach unten verlinkt
hier ist jetzt noch mein boden für die
untere täters gestern übrigens gebacken
da habe ich nebenbei im film auf netflix
geguckt zwar total entspannt und ich lös
jetzt sehr einfach mit einem backform
löser und dann könnt ihr das ganze
entweder in alufolie oder wovon nicht
ein größerer firmen das einfach in
frischhaltefolie einschlagen schön eng
und in den kühlschrank und wie gesagt
dass es dann am nächsten tag einfach
viel besser zu verarbeiten
[Musik]
so die böden werden also erledigt und
als nächstes brauchen wir eine kanal
stellen diese torte wird mit fondant
überzogen und ihr könnt jetzt nicht alle
cremes dann außen bestreichen weil der
von dann schmilzt zum beispiel bei krebs
die sehr viel feuchtigkeit enthalten ihr
könnt zum beispiel keine sahne muss
capone cremes oder quark krems verwenden
weil davon wirklich binnen weniger
stunden weg schmelzen würde und ich
mache immer gerne so dass ich trotzdem
diese seine cremes mit einbauen und dann
aber ein ganache regen drumherum spritze
und alles auch mit ghanas bestreichen
das zeige ich euch gleich wie ich das
mache aber zuerst müssen wir die
vorbereiten das habe ich auch am vortag
gemacht ganz entspannt weil das schöne
ist wenn ihr die garage zimmertemperatur
einfach über nacht stehen lassen dann
wird sie richtig schön geschmeidig hier
zum beispiel ich habe eine mit weißer
schokolade und einem zart bitter gemacht
also es wird so eine richtig schöne
streichfähige konsistenz ist mir schon
fast ein bisschen zu weich deshalb ist
gleich nochmal in den kühlschrank
stellen und genau und dann zeige ich
euch jetzt einfach wie ich das gestern
gemacht habe ihr nehmt euch jetzt
einfach in einem ganz bestimmten
verhältnis übrigens kuvertüre ihr könnt
auch schokolade nehmen also ob ihr eine
tafel schokolade oder kultur ist an der
stelle egal das wird eine schöne feier
geharkt und wichtig ist dass wir dann
auf jeden fall seine verwenden und ich
schreibe euch das verhältnis natürlich
auch unten in die infobox und dann wird
das schön fein gehackten eine schüssel
gegeben die sahne wird gleich erwärmt
achtung dass die nicht ganz so doll
hochkocht und habt ihr gleich eine
sauerei und dann gießen wir das thema
und lassen das schmelzen da kann es auch
helfen wenn ihr das gleich einfach
fünften noch mit einem teller überdeckt
damit es schön in der eigenen erhitzte
schon anfang an zu schmelzen und ihr
halt ganz einfach umrühren könnt
[Musik]
also galt es an sich sehr einfach
zuzubereiten bei der weißen ganache muss
man ein bisschen aufpassen denn da ist
das verhältnis sahne zu weißer kuvertüre
so wenig sahne vier kuvertüre und da
kann es sein dass wir vielleicht mal ein
zwei tütchen noch mit drin habe die sich
nicht auflösen dann könnt ihr auch die
schüssel einfach bei geringer war zwar
immer für 10 15 eine mikrowelle tun
immer wieder umrühren und ich finde
gerade hier sieht man die konsistenzen
jetzt vor und nach der kühlkette ist
natürlich noch warm und dann fließt die
schokolade ist schon sehr flüssig und
hier die abgekühlte danach das weiß auf
zimmertemperatur ist auf jeden fall
fester geworden ich muss sagen da durch
das wird auch warme temperaturen haben
ist mir das noch zu weich also wie grad
schon erwähnt gebe ich das bag nummer in
den kühlschrank das könnt ihr auch zwei
tage lang auf zimmertemperatur stehen
lassen die verdirbt nicht oder so wenn
erst ganze woche vorher vorbereiten
möchte etwas auch geht einfach im
kühlschrank lagern dann wird sie sehr
fest dann könnt ihr sie einfach noch mal
einen tag vor herausholen oder was ja
auch machen könnte wenn ihr keine zeit
habt einfach nochmal erwerben entweder
in der mikrowelle oder über dem
wasserbad dann wird es sehr sehr weich
also so wie hier praktisch und dann
könnt ihr da immer so ein bisschen
mitspielen kühlschrank das verbot
kühlschrank wasserbad bis er die
perfekte konsistenz habt und jetzt
geht's an die leckere creme da habe ich
ja schon gesagt er möchte ich im inneren
gerne eine leckere seine mascarpone
creme und durch den garten kann man was
ja auch ganz gut darin verarbeiten also
wie gesagt von land und das funktioniert
nicht ganz aber das kriegen wir heute
mit einem schönen trick hin ich habe
jetzt hier doppel raum frischkäse und
mascarpone hier nehme ich immer gerne
philadelphia das ist für mich so der
geschmack neutral und ich finde es
schmeckt halt auch mal sehr frisch ihr
könnt jetzt natürlich auch quark
unterrühren ich weiß viele sind auch fan
von einfach fragen unter zu hören weil
sie vielleicht ein bisschen leichter
schmeckt wobei ich finde diese creme
schmeckt auch sehr leicht fallen weil
ich gleich noch frische früchte dazu
gehöre aber
die torte die unten ist die wird er dann
auch durch quark etwas unstabiler und
deshalb müsst ihr auch daran denken wenn
ihnen ich wollte dass eure toto zusammen
sagt da gibt es zwar auch gleich tricks
wie ihr das vermeiden können das zeige
ich euch gleich aber die creme ist halt
die basis und da müsst ihr dann schon
eine sehr stabile creme auswählen daher
habe ich jetzt auch nicht so einen
großen anteil an sahen aber wenn ihnen
die aufschlag bist ja auch sehr sehr
viel fähig und auch nicht allzu stabil
wo habe ich jetzt mit puderzucker hier
genauso dazu liebe ich da jetzt noch mit
dazu und als basis also geschmackliche
basis nämlich vanille das mag jeder das
liebt ihre ich hab mir auch schon die
böden und vanille könnt ihr gleich auch
dazu geben und dann fange ich an das
erst mal nur kurz ein bisschen zusammen
zu gehen ein paar sekunden um 10
sekunden und dann gebe ich die sahne
dazu und lass es komplett steif schlagen
und damit komplett stabil ist könnt ihr
dann auch zwischendrin auch schon lange
fest einrieseln lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so die creme für unsere füllung ist
fertig werde ich gleich auch noch mal
kühl stellen weil wir ja gleich erst
verwenden denn jetzt werden wir erst mal
unsere böden
durchschneiden ich habe hier meine
torten säge schon parat und was ich mir
auch schon mit genommen habt ist eine
torten ram folie es ist jetzt kein muss
aber es erleichtert euch so ein bisschen
die sache wegen dem garant nachher das
heißt falls seine torten randvoll ihr
habt verwendet sie sehr sehr gerne und
hatte gleich keinen stress ich verlinke
ihr euch auch genauso wie alle anderen
utensilien und nun die infobox dann
nehme ich wahrscheinlich jetzt die ganz
lange es habe aber auch noch zwei
weitere größen da das komme ich dann
gleich einfach je nachdem wie viele
bereits raus kommen und wie hoch das
ganze wird und dann könnt ihr gerne die
böden immer so ungefähr eineinhalb
zentimeter
hoch durchschneiden und wie viele da
rauskommen ist dann eigentlich relativ
individuell aber ich denke dass jedoch
schon ordentlich viele böden raus kommen
weil der ist schon extrem hoch geworden
[Musik]
ich hab mir gerade die böden schon
durchgeschnitten unten habe ich viel
böden rausbekommen den oberen als meine
bis gebacken zwar schon recht gerade
aber hier soll es wirklich komplett
akkurat gerade sein daher hatte ich den
auch oben noch weggeschnitten ein
bisschen verschnitt habe ich also gleich
zum naschen und was ich ja auch schon
vorbereitet das hätte ich fast vergessen
die frischen früchte jetzt ist ja gerade
zum beispiel erdbeersaison daherkomme
frische erdbeeren in die untere etage
und nicht nehmen noch aprikosen diesen
dabei aus der dose die nehme ich für die
obere etage und ich erinnere mich noch
genau an meine verlobung übrigens diese
torte sven beste freundin die sich
verlobt wir sind seit der zweiten klasse
best friends und dann hat sich bis heute
nichts geändert meine verlobungs dort
habe ich damals selber gemacht und das
ist auch so ein stress
ich habe ja nicht nur die verlobung
stalker gemacht sondern ich habe noch so
kleine desserts gemacht die mache ich
meine freundin übrigens auch zeige ich
euch dann auf tik tok oder in seoul ich
kannte hier auch als shorts hochladen
und ich war halt bei mir so müde weil
ich diese zweistöckige torte jetzt will
ich mir angucke finde ich die total
hässlich aber damals war ich so stolz
auf mich aber ich war so müde am
nächsten tag und anhang dieser kiki bis
sofort packt doch nicht eine eigene
verlobung stored das doch toll der
stress jetzt wirklich nur diese kleinen
desserts gemacht dann hätte ich noch so
eine urio süße und lassen ihre macht und
so weiter das war schon stress und ich
habe ja noch ein foto davon ist blenden
wir euch mal ein aber nachher denkt mir
so doch man ist schon ganz schön stolz
auf dich in dem moment na ja ich nehme
hier jetzt mal fröhlich weiter ich mache
schon sehr sehr fein wichtig ist bitte
ordentlich abtupfen dass sie sollten
nicht mehr ganz so nach seien vom
waschen auch die aprikosen richtig
ordentlich abtupfen mit küchenpapier und
dann geben die auch nicht mehr so viel
feuchtigkeit ab
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt so weit alles
vorbereitet die torten rand folie ist
außen herum ich hab den ersten boden und
runter getan und am boden habe ich noch
ein cache bord das ist das war auf der
einen seite gold noch schwarz ist
einfach für mich angenehmer weil ich das
gleich den kühlschrank verstauen kann
und noch nicht nur hohe tortenplatte
darunter habt ihr könnt euch aussuchen
nimmt er jetzt den xxl torten bringen
oderberg dem klassischen in dem fall
geht das sogar mit dem klassischen weil
die torten rand folie verlängert ja
quasi den ring und sind mir zuallererst
die garage und
sicher jetzt gleich meine sahne creme
abo dafür einfach in garching
aufspritzen er könnte entweder einmal
umgehen oder weil es sehr flach ist geht
lieber zweimal drumherum notfalls sogar
dreimal um einfach so ein ja so einen
hohen rand zu erschaffen damit ihr quasi
eure creme oder euren fondant besser
gesagt vor der creme schützt und sobald
ihr das dann gemacht habt ich hab
nämlich gerade schon die früchte
geschnibbelt könnt ihr gleich auf jeden
fall schon mal die creme bestreichen und
noch die früchte dazu packen so sobald
ihr dann mit eurem gerne schrägen
zufrieden weiter muss halt auch nicht so
perfekt sein das sieht man nachher
sowieso alles nicht mehr könnt ihr wie
gesagt die creme dazutun ich habe nur
einen trick für euch ich habe hier meine
winkel palette ihr könntet im prinzip
den garagen auch hier noch mal so ein
bisschen verstreichen es mache ich
manchmal ganz gerne aber so wenn ich
schon ganz happy und dann kommt wie
gesagt die creme dazwischen das coole
ist diese creme verwenden wir jetzt für
beide etagen das ist eine leckere
vanillecreme und die wird dann halt je
nach etage noch mit früchten verfeinert
wollt ihr unten gern die erdbeeren
nehmen die habe ich einfach sehr fein
geschnibbelt so dass ich sie gleich
einfach oben draufpacken kann und dann
machen glück was sie immer so weiter bis
hier oben an sind also eigentlich ganz
easy
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt ganz oben angekommen
vielleicht habt ihr es gemerkt ich habe
den boden von unterboden als deckel
quasi genommen ist jetzt kein muss aber
dann habt ihr einfach die emporen
geschlossen und könnte jetzt nochmal mit
ghanas abschließen ohne dass ihr euch
diesen fluffigen angeschnittenen boden
wegreißt wir schließen das jetzt deshalb
mit ghanas noch ab bevor wir das kühlen
weil das ja auch nochmal schützen soll
jetzt einfach den rest von einem
spritzbeutel noch hier weg und dann habt
ihr halt nicht die gefahr dass während
das jetzt kühlt dass es oben austrocknet
weil so fluffig diese biscuit böden auch
sind wenn die nicht geschützt sind dann
können sie auch mal ganz schön trocken
werden das tolle ist dadurch das wird
auch diese sehr feuchte füllung haben
kann das dann in den stunden in denen
das zieht noch mal richtig schön die
feuchtigkeit aufsaugen und die böden
wenn du dich noch flüssiger bin
eigentlich auch fan davon böden zu
tränken mit irgendeinem saft oder so
aber das brauchte hier gar nicht weil
wie gesagt diese diese feuchtigkeit von
der saane mascarpone philadelphia kleben
die ist einfach perfekt und nachdem ich
das jetzt hier schön eingestrichen hat
muss auch noch nicht so schön gerade
sein es kommt später erst bereite ich
schon mal die obere etage vor das heißt
da auch einfach die torten rand folie
drumherum geben und dann nehme ich
wahrscheinlich hier den xxl tortenring
weil hier das ok hier ist es ja ein
bisschen drüber aber man sollte jetzt
auch nicht alles komplett bis oben
schichten weil so stabil ist sie halt
nicht und da ist ein tortenring immer
besser
[Musik]
so ich hab so weit alles vorbereitet und
pack märz wieder gerne in meinen
spritzbeutel mit lochte vorne dran und
er viele sind ja dann auch immer so dass
sie sagen aber ich muss er die torte
dann zeitnah also kurz vor dem event
quasi backen und dann immer sofort
servieren weil es könnte ja sein dass
ich schlecht wird aber eigentlich könnte
da ganz entspannt sein aber im prinzip
hält ja diese torte drei tage lang und
wenn samstag zum beispiel die
verlobungsparty oder die hochzeitsfeier
ist dann könntet ihr schon
am donnerstag anfangen beziehungsweise
die ganache sogar schon eine woche
vorher machen eigentlich müsste ich mal
ein video machen was das zeitmanagement
angeht für bestimmte torten projekt da
wenn ihr daran interessiert sei dann
schreibt das gerne weil ich das auch bei
meinen anderen videos wenn ich zb eine
sahnetorte oder so zubereitet kommt
immer ganz auf die frage kann ich das
auch schon am vortag machen und das geht
eigentlich zu 99,9 prozent immer daher
dürft ihr euch da gar keinen stress
machen gerade wenn man vielleicht auch
noch andere sachen zu tun hat vor seiner
feier genau ich mache jetzt einfach so
weiter wie bisher
mein gerne schrägen diesmal die helle
ganache aufspritzen dann kommt da wieder
die creme rein diesmal ja die aprikosen
füllung und dann werde ich die sechs
bilden zwei schichten der sich um
angekommen
[Musik]
die obere etage ist jetzt auch reggae
habe ich jetzt in den kühlschrank getan
die untere schicht dürfte er jetzt
kühlen in der zwischenzeit daher können
wir hier einmal den tortenring und die
torten rand folie entfernen und jetzt
müssen wir das quasi zweimal
einstreichen mit der garage die wollen
wir auch in der zwischenzeit werden wir
auch die klimaanlagen in der
zwischenzeit war sie mir auch relativ
fest geworden dann haben wir sie immer
wieder für 30 sekunden bei 600 watt eine
mikrowelle erwärmt damit sie wieder
schön streichfähig wird das nun mal so
als tipp am rande also ihr könnt da
wirklich immer wieder erwärmen erkalten
lassen und so weiter bis ihr die
perfekte konsistenz erreicht habt so
jetzt aber noch hier die kleber abmachen
torten rand folie entfernt und ihr könnt
falls jetzt gerade eine turm brennt
folie nicht da habt aber stattdessen in
den hohen tortenring könnte hier noch
das xxl tortenring das ansonsten
verwenden richtig schön rein gehen denn
auch der garant wird ja fest und es kann
euch dadurch passiert das passiert
garantiert dass ihr euch an so einen
batzen wegreißt und daher auf jeden fall
entweder mit der torten ram folien
schützen oder ein
pöttering messer verwenden oder
vielleicht auch beides kommt immer
darauf an wie kalt ist dann bei euch ist
und sie fertig geworden ist also machen
sie jetzt so dass ich dann wirklich
meine torte einmal mit der gerner
einstreichen da müsst ihr noch nicht so
ordentlich im so genau sein das ist die
krümel bindung us asset ist feiern
gerade ich muss sommer drehen und rennt
kühlwetter also wir können erst dann
noch mal und dann kommt die zweite
schicht die wir dann richtig schön
ordentlich und gerade das ist die
vorbereitung für unseren verband
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt anfange die obere etage
einzustreichen ganz ganz wichtig wir
brauchen topspiele es würden auch strom
funktionieren aber 51 von cake pops stil
muss ich ehrlich sagen weil man hat dann
mich diesen also wenn dann braucht ihr
diese cocktail strohhalme gibt es
überhaupt noch ich glaub das wird er
jetzt gerade auch verboten und habe da
halt so auch so ein loch drin und dann
ja hab da auch was vom kuchen weg aber
ihr könnt cake pops viele verwenden
damit stabil bleibt und einfach
anzuwenden
reinstecken achtet von natürlich auch
auf die höhe sollte jetzt nicht raus
tragen bei mir ist es jetzt gerade durch
zufall einfach perfekt in die untere
etage kommen gleich auch noch topspieler
aber die werden wir auf jeden fall zu
schneiden das zeige ich euch dann und
beim anschnitt und so da braucht euch
keine sorgen machen ihr wisst ja dass
vier oder fünf paybox stile einzig noch
in die mitte drin sind und dadurch kippt
eure torte halt nicht nach rechts oder
nach links weil dadurch dass sie sehr
hoch ist nein sie wirklich mit der zeit
dazu irgendwie zu kippen aber so
verhindert ihr das genau und jetzt fange
ich an das ganze einzustreichen
[Musik]
jetzt wurden beide etagen einmal erst
mal grob eingestrichen ich habe ca 15
minuten so kühlt das reicht erst mal von
anstand und jetzt fange ich an mit der
unteren etage das noch mal richtig schön
gerade einzustreichen am besten nehmt
euch dafür so die standard winkel
palette und ein ein xxl teig karte und
eine drehbare tortenplatte weil dann
könnt ihr das immer schön abziehen und
hier ist wie gesagt wichtig dass das so
akkurat und gerade wie möglich gemacht
wird weil die schüler ihr das jetzt
einstreicht umso schöner sieht dann das
ergebnis zusammen mit dem von land aus
[Musik]
so beide torten sind gerade im
kühlschrank eine halbe stunde brauchen
sie damit die letzte schicht auch schön
fest wird und wir die torten mit fondant
überziehen können ich habe einfach die
arbeitsfläche ein bisschen mit kokosfett
benetzt sind eingerieben und meine hände
sind auch voller kokosfett jetzt könnte
einfach den verband so ein bisschen
geschmeidig kneten und anschließend auf
der gefetteten arbeitsfläche ausrollen
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach breit
weiter so ein richtig schönes weiß ich
werde das auch nicht einfärben und das
verlegen ich euch auch so gerne in der
infobox bekommt ja auch bei uns im shop
viele wissen das gar nicht aber wir
haben nicht alles so gefühlt wie gesagt
ich knete das jetzt werde das gleich
einfach schön fein ausbreiten gar nicht
zu dick aber auch nicht zu dünn und dann
werden beide torten quasi mit der
fondant decke
überzogen also falls ihr euch wundert es
ist total am donner und blitzen draußen
vielleicht hat man sorge abgehört und es
ist voll die weltuntergangsstimmung was
einmal so dunkel wurde aber angst hat
vor 15 30 oder sonne egal wann das beste
das wir backen hier fröhlich auch selbst
orte
[Musik]
den von dann könnt ihr mit kokosfett am
besten durch kneten aber das ausrollen
könnt ihr damit becker stärke machen das
ist ganz ganz ganz feine stärke und dann
habt ihr euch auch nissan und ihr könnt
es perfekt einschlagen den von dann
gerne noch die renner so ein bisschen
begradigen aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
bei dieser hochzeitstorte ist eigentlich
alles gar kein problem weil recht kommt
noch eine dekoration um drauf wo man ihn
nicht sieht ob wir da irgendwo
luftbläschen drin habe sondern irgendwo
euch ein fauxpas passiert ist daher ich
finde diese erzeugnisse relativ anfänger
geeignet also ich meine wenn er quasi
hat die anfänge mit vonlanthen macht
somit motiv torten dann diese torte
locker hin selbst stapel ich beides ich
habe jetzt hier nochmal meine cake pops
stille ich dich dass hier einmal in die
mitte und dann müsste ich mir quasi
notieren dann nehme ich mir
das
quasi abgeschnitten werden muss und dann
mache ich mir da auch noch insgesamt
fünf cake pops stile in derselben höhe
fertig wichtig ist dass ihr wirklich
genau die exakt gleiche höhe verwendet
damit wird dann die zweite etage wo ihr
unten drunter auch im jackpot ist es ist
ganz ganz wichtig sind sagt euch ein die
kann man dann gleich oben drüber tun und
ihm müssten in der regel noch ein
bisschen ganz üblich haben dann könnt
ihr das auch direkt kleber benutzen
[Musik]
seit zeige ich euch eine einfache aber
wirkungsvolle
hochzeitsdekoration und nehmt euch
einfach wieder den weißen von dann den
heute dann auf etwas becker stärke aus
nicht zu dickes soll sich zu schwer sein
aber auch nicht zu dünn also vom gefühl
her würde ich sagen 3 mm und dann machen
wir mit hilfe von strohhalm ein richtig
tolles
luftiges eine fluffige dekoration lässt
ganz was es genau darstellen soll aber
ich habe das jetzt auch schon jetzt
öfter gesehen das hat mir sehr gut
gefallen und ich finde auch vor allem
kann man da auch so kleine fehlerchen
kaschieren kann hier für dich einen
sprachfehler habe es nicht mehr jeden
fall zeige ich euch jetzt trotz euch
einfach einmal das sagt immer viel mehr
als tausend worte es ist so einfach und
dann könnt ihr das ganz einfach
nachmachen und ich habe frische blumen
gerade besorgt die sie vielleicht schon
hier im hintergrund die werde ich gleich
auch noch dazu tun und dann ist die
hochzeitstorte fertig
[Musik]
so fertig ist meine hochzeitstorte also
ich sag ja das ist eine torte die
verzeiht sehr sehr viel das heißt wenn
ihr zum beispiel irgendwo im von dante
fleck habt oder einriss habt dann könnt
ihr das perfekt kaschieren und die
blumen die habe ich ja noch in
strohhalme also ich den den stil
praktischen strohhalm reingesteckt damit
auch hygienischer ist und ich persönlich
am morgen ist erst die feier richtig
persönlich werde die blumen gleich auch
noch mal rausnehmen und in wasser tun
oder nochmal frische blumen zu tun aber
ich wollte euch einfach zeigen wie ich
das dekorieren würde ihr könnt jetzt
natürlich auch zum beispiel so ein paper
ich finde dass sie mit dem holz
compuserve könnte noch drauf stecken
oder einfach auch die namen vom pärchen
und da da ich jetzt nicht probieren kann
weil ich hier richtig anscheinend habe
ich aus den resten ganz ganz ganz
bisschen das noch übrig gewinnen habe
ich so schicht desserts gezaubert und
dann kann ich mir auch zumindest
vorstellen ich kenne ja auch ein
bisschen boden grundrezept ich kenne die
creme weil ich weiß wie das schmeckt
aber einen kleinen test es noch zur
feier des tages
sehr frisch also wird es ist nicht
schwer oder so das einzige was sein kann
ist dass mit dem von dann zu süß wird
aber ich muss sagen das lässt man ja
auch mittlerweile auch einfach auf dem
teller liegen weil das ist ja eher so
kurz weg genommen also ich hoffe
natürlich dass ich meine hochzeitstorte
gefallen hat und wenn ihr das ganze nach
macht übernimmt ein foto schicken über
instagram folgt mir dort auch gerne
folgt mit tik tok dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten rezeptideen ski team
[Musik]